In many cases, we ask users to
type out the same information,
even when the website
has their information.
For example, think about name, address,
telephone number, email,
credit card, etc.
Would it be cool to offer a shortcut
that saves time, typing, and money?
>> Yeah.
You know, retailers often use past
orders to suggest future inputs.
Because once they've
already collected and
saved your address why ask for it again?
>> Yeah, and it makes life less
frustrating for your users.
It also a good idea to ask permission.
For example Amazon ask
which saves address to use.
But be careful.
If your application fills in too much,
users might get the wrong information.
For example, shipping your
package to the wrong address.
Remember, reusing information
will make your forms faster.